what is it about Hillary that bothers
explain the Howard share from Hillary is
a mess okay and we're going to we're
going to reward with the presidency a
woman who has enabled him you know the
depredations and the Indian and the
exploitation of women okay by that by
the unify them you know cornpone husband
first and so on I mean is that the way
feminism feminist medicines blind okay
to to Hillary's record okay you know of
trashing if there were going to try to
store Monica Lewinsky so um I mean it's
a scandal anyone who believes in sexual
harassment guidelines okay
should have seen that the disparity of
power between Clinton in Monica Lewinsky
was one of the most grotesque ever again
in the history of sex crime
he's a sex criminal against fellow Oh
we're gonna put that guy back in the
White House okay
she this was Hillary's written on his
coattails yeah she this is not a woman
who has her own career later on a career
chichi tell mama no failed the bar exam
in Washington
you